let's talk about this here news we got
uh so uh i got a text message just a
moment ago literally a few within a few
minutes of going live in the show
from crowder and he was just like
telling me what happened and the story
is absolutely insane you may have heard
about the loudoun county scandal where
there was a student who was uh harmed
their an arrest was made and i i can't i
didn't realize this because we were
actually we actually talked about this a
little bit yesterday uh during the show
but apparently
telling the context of this major
breaking news story which is having a
serious effect on how the ag is acting
and responding to parents
crowder got a strike over this they've
suspended him for a week and i have this
email check this out
this is this is what uh youtube has
written
we write again on youtube's behalf
regarding i'm sorry i believe it's their
legal counsel we write again on
youtube's behalf regarding your client
stephen crowder youtube has repeatedly
instructed mr crowder regarding its hate
speech policy and warned him against
continuing violations of that policy
through content he uploaded to youtube
youtube specifically informed mr crowder
that videos he uploaded show a pattern
of recklessly targeting the lgbtq plus
community for abuse and insults it
warned that further uploading of content
that targets insults and or abuses the
lgbtq community would result in
additional penalties on september 30th
mr crowder uploaded another video that
youtube has determined continues his
prior conduct the video entitled special
guest alex jones on great reset and joe
rogan who triggers leftists again
contains a segment that targets the
transgender community in a defensive
manner for example by indicating that
trans people pose a rape threat to women
consistent with the recklessness
provision of its hate speech policy
youtube has removed this video from the
service and assessed a strike against
the stephen crowder channel for youtube
strikes policy this results in a
one-week upload freeze for the channel
further violation of youtube's hate
speech policy will result in additional
penalties
one additional note when an account is
restricted from using youtube features
the channel operator is prohibited from
using any other channel to get around
the applicable restrictions your client
may not use another youtube channel such
as crowderbits channel to bypass the
upload restrictions on the stephen
crowder channel such conduct may subject
all of his channels to termination very
truly yours counsel for youtube
now i don't know exactly what steven
said or how he framed it but i cannot
imagine
that it would warrant a takedown it's a
major breaking story
i think it's it's particularly dangerous
that we're in an era now where opinions
are editorial there's an editorial
guideline for for big services that you
are not allowed to express yourself
online if your opinion doesn't fall in
line with the editorial guidelines of
youtube
you know this is disturbing on many
levels because this is about a specific
documented case when children got hurt i
mean this is a big case this deserves to
be talked about but it can't and what
crowder said i don't know i don't i
don't watch him i've been critical of
him before but to have his voice kind of
eliminated here is a very big deal there
deserves to be a conversation that there
deserves to be some kind of debate here
and we're being denied that people are
not hearing about this very important
story which they should uh and that to
me is the biggest travesty of injustice
personally because at the same time
crowded as his show whether you like it
or not you have to understand the
mainstream media gets away with showing
horrible stuff on youtube whether it's
gore whether it's it's stories that are
more hyperbolic more sensational more
gross more detailed and and and they got
caught many times lying through their
teeth let me i want to say two quick
things for one you guys
louderwithcrowder.com you can join the
mug club you can help support them
they're going to be doing their show on
their website this is why we have the
websites this is why crowder's got his
websites why we got our website so that
in the event maybe we'll get a strike
for simply talking about this and me
reading what the email said and that's
why we have the website up so that we
can at least have something active in
the event we we get hit by youtube but
we're not going to sit back and accept
it so the story is very simple there was
in in loudoun county a father this is
the daily wire reporting this news guard
certified all that good stuff reporting
that a child was assaulted will keep the
language family friendly but it was in a
bathroom and there was an arrest made
crowder talked about the story
to be fair i don't know exactly how he
framed it but still regardless this is a
major breaking news story we have more
development developments on this that
we're going to be talking about and i
think it's particularly dangerous
we are enter
what more needs to be said that you
haven't heard me say 50 billion times
when you homogenize the political space
you don't end the opinions of these
people they exist they're alive they're
going to live for for 50 more years
between you know how how how old are the
people who are paying attention paying
attention to politics right now let's
say they're 18 to 2 to 70. okay so we're
gonna have a long period of people
holding these views they want to express
censoring them just makes them find
alternative means crowder of course
isn't going anywhere he's going to keep
doing his show on his own platform all
youtube is doing is hyper polarizing the
space by shutting down these
conversations what i think is
interesting one is that apparently two
spirits are full or fair game because
it's not listed it's not listed up there
uh but second is this is this is the end
result of what's been happening for many
years where you turn uh an insult
into abuse
right it says abuse and insults like how
are those even the same things abuse is
chronic ongoing and it prohibits you
from doing the thing that you're
supposed to do whether it's live life or
have a job or get education
and insult is just part of life right
it's a part of life so what they're
saying now is that they're they're
criminalizing bombing effectively uh or
prohibiting insults it sounds like but
they didn't even name who these are
minors and other names are released this
is not targeting any specific apparently
it's just making an insult about the
lgbtq plus community they were saying
it's repetitive insults which i guess
you could consider abuse
no no abuse abuse has to has to prevent
you from doing something that you
ordinarily would want to do like live a
healthy productive life
hold on to the problem with that is they
argue when i'm insulted i get scared and
i shut down so like
their delicacy is not my concern right
this is like second and third order
effects of us transitioning away from an
honor culture to a victim culture where
victim victimology gives you status and
so now you can claim status by being
first it was abused then it was harassed
now it's insulted and soon it'll be even
thought improperly there are but nobody
sorry i'm sorry nobody complained about
this so this must have been somebody
internal right right right i i don't
think crowder i don't think any
individual was named in this story well
again it's it says about the community
itself so you can't even insult like if
dave chappelle came in here and did one
of his bits they'd get your show taken
down right yep yeah which is crazy
because i don't know dave chappelle
never seemed to be too far outside if
cnn came here and did a segment this
channel would be terminated immediately
for like half of their content that they
put out there that's deemed again just
based out of their lives that would be
the one time we appear on the front page
yeah they'd be like see we're fair look
the tim cast irela's on the front page
i'm like yeah because don lemon was the
guest i would love i would love to have
don lemon as a guest i would love to
have anderson cooper i had many
interactions with him in parking lots
that were pretty interesting to say the
least wait did you say parking lots i
almost made a joke that might get the
challenge yeah watch your watch
i actually would would would love to
have a conversation with anderson cooper
hell yeah bring them on it'll be
extremely entertaining to say the least
my conversations with them were pretty
entertaining already but but again
there's this duplicity here there's this
hypocrisy here because again they're
playing by different rules i i think
that you know the independent community
is being micromanaged to the point of
absurdity there's there's these rules
and there's these
unspoken rules we don't know the exact
circumstances but but where do you draw
the line when talking about documented
specific cases and stories about actual
victims that need to be heard i mean
imagine being this girl or this father
already uh we can't even get into the
details here but but there is
allegations of cover-up already
happening now this is happening on top
of that imagine being such a victim to
the point where your story can't even
get out there to the general public no
one should even hear your story that to
me is even the bigger crime here this is
this like
it's look
it sounds soviet
i i have uh there's a friend of mine
that i've known for years that i've hung
out with in various countries who's from
ukraine and these are the stories that i
would hear
about you know when you when to be fair
like the soviet union collapsed when we
were kids but to be like oh yeah this is
what my parents warned me about this is
what they said how it started and this
is what they were scared of it's things
like this
certain things aren't allowed to be
talked about just like the story itself
can't be talked about the concerns of
the parents can't be talking it's weird
because it's youtube is kind of like a
common space now because it's supposedly
it's still a private company but it's a
common carrier like going out in the
street and talking in the middle of the
road with your friends in poland
information against the state was
criminalized if you gave out flyers and
pamphlets that were win against the
state went against the commies
you would get jail time you'd get put
into the prison camps some people would
get tortured for simply just expressing
political ideas and i think this is not
we're not at that level yet but we're at
a moment where it could be a very easy
slippery slope and also when i mean
parking lots with anderson cooper uh
don't get ideas like dirty minded jack
here
you can see the videos you can see the
videos on youtube.com we are checking
what do you mean we are changing
anderson cooper we are change anderson
uber you'll see the videos maybe if they
come up what he means is where were we
at the dnc or this was a number of times
i talked to anderson cooper in numbers
with luke and anderson cooper's walking
around i was like oh hey looks anderson
cooper and then luke runs up and goes
why did you intern at the cia are you
familiar with project mockingbird and he
was like
what are you talking about yes first of
all but he was all friendly he was all
cheery talking to everyone i was like
hey i came off nice all right i didn't
come off that aggressive at first i
always kind of you know
get there hi anderson how you doing and
then you know you got to get in there
with some serious questions
i think it's important your your example
about in poland in communist countries
you know i'm obviously i'm a free speech
advocate i'm not an advocate of tyranny
i'm not advocating of communism i'm
going to get nailed on this later for
being some sort of communist
totalitarian now but like i at least
understand the logic behind suppressing
speech that criticizes the the state
that's in power like that makes sense to
me it's like we want to maintain our
power over everybody so yeah you can't
say this it's a bad thing but it is a
bad thing but i understand the logic
there this i don't necessarily
understand we're talking about equations
well this is the slippery slope extreme
minority cases here i think the problem
is i didn't see what steve did that got
him banned and he might have been
insulting people again like and if he
does it over and over
hold on hold on hold on hold on i look
in the group when like i or i see
somebody get made fun of over and over
and over and then they start crying and
then they feel like they can't be
themselves and they go home and they
want to they hit themselves in the face
because they're so okay okay now now
let's talk about every single trump
supporter who's been labeled a a a slack
jawed yokel who's been mocked and
belittled endlessly on main on on
mainstream tv and then they just say
white men are not a minority group and
i'm like i'm literally talking about the
like the viral there's a black woman who
does really great videos where she just
rebuts all of these lies because there's
an eclectic group of people who either
voted for trump or conservative who are
just berated and insulted all day every
day and this is exactly what i said to
jack dorsey
why are you singling out one community
for special protection and not any other
exactly but but
this is what i was saying he said look
when it comes to the transgender
community there's a high suicide rate so
we're very you know we're very partial
to that and then i said what about any
other community with high rates of
suicide like like police for instance my
understanding military military uh no
they don't care now now to be fair to be
fair they i'm pretty sure they do have a
rule against disparaging veterans no
joke i don't know exactly how that works
but i'm pretty sure they don't enforce
it the internet is built off of
insulting people you look at the
algorithms you look at twitter you look
at facebook what do they promote what do
they put on their timeline that's
carefully curated for you drama fighting
always at the top the i think it's a
part of a larger divide and conquer
agenda but if you're gonna start uh
policing insulting people that's another
level of absurdity that there's no going
back from and and jack you can
understand the logic but understand this
is the beginning of a lot more bigger
problems don't attack me like i'm
supporting it
i don't but but i'm just trying to add
another point to what you're saying that
it begins with this kind of absurdity
that you're questioning i don't
understand why they're doing you're
going to understand it once it ratchets
up and it comes to the point where you
go to jail for expressing a thought and
an idea indeed someone someone super
chatted us just now they said that
crowder did a skit about california
women's prisons handing out condoms
oh my so so maybe maybe maybe that i
don't know for sure that's part of it
but i don't know if he actually did that
i'm just saying someone's he's like a
bee that refuses to stop stinging
well you know if you're gonna if you're
gonna go after him you gotta go after
dave chappelle now you don't have and
then if you go after dave chappelle
you're gonna go after jimmy kimmel and
then after jimmy kimmel you go to jimmy
you guys chef cancel everyone but he's
on a youtube channel and he kept making
fun of a certain type of person dave
chappelle does that's what dave does
channel he does it on like netflix
behind the scenes on a pay wall yo
netflix has a youtube channel these
clips are all available on youtube but
he doesn't steve goes on like every day
and does this stuff with a holstered gun
in his in his pocket no he doesn't he's
like all like he's very a like a an
oppressive force that were true ian
they'd have given him a strike on every
single video he did
unfortunately it's admins making
decisions at will it's not like a robot
i got to sit here and listen to the
psychotic ramblings of msnbc joy reid
rachel maddow the hate speech the
insults the vile disgusting behavior and
you know what i get it i'm an adult yet
crowder does one segment on a news story
and maybe he was doing a skit regardless
do i what about when when you get was it
jimmy kimmel doing blackface yeah yeah
they do all of these things and and and
i think it's very very obvious what this
is if you are outside of the controlled
establishment narrative you are fair
game everyone else is fine i think you
made a good point that
that going hard on minorities has really
cracked down on going hard on people
that they think are majorities is fine
well as soon as america becomes the uh
white minority nation that everyone is
is projecting do you think that they're
going to apply those same standards to
white people
depends on if they want to make
themselves
who are they in there's people on the
mainstream media literally arguing that
you can't be racist to white people
because of the way that they were born
and that you could get away with
whatever you want to get away with
because they have privileged
exactly but that is allowed that is
promoted that is put in the algorithm
that is put in the rankings that is
showed to people far and wide with
unfair privileges to multinational
corporations that get the advantage over
independent media and still somehow
independent media is kicking their butts
still
breathing for life and now they're going
to be nitpicking on what you can and
cannot say it's ridiculous if they're
going to go after stephen crowder like
this go take down the netflix youtube
channel for hosting dave chappelle go
take down jimmy kimball go take all of
them down and then maybe you could
lecture us about what is rightfully to
do about abuse and her get bull crap out
of here i'm sick of it and it's and it's
ridiculous i don't give a damn what his
name is he doesn't deserve james me to
even pronounce his name right
i'm sick of him sick of him he's
literally doing a song and dancer and
that's cool bear but but they're
literally they're literally chilling to
the point where they're spreading
dangerous fake news about people lining
up in the hospital not being able to get
help because of poison control
ivermectin use look at this and that's
not true at all
it went after children these all these
conditions after kids might like these
are minors
fine you weren't you yeah i just the
last point i want to make is like
education is so important and when i
mean education i mean the education
industry a lot of this stuff stems from
2011 dear colleague letter for title ix
where they made it so that all
universities had to extinguish not just
abuse not just harassment but people
being made uncomfortable so now it's
been 10 years where these universities
are forced to do this or lose their
funding where they set up bias response
teams and secret hotlines to report on
fellow students that said something that
made you feel uncomfortable and those
kids get sanctioned and there's no
hearings and there's no trials and
there's no you know representation
there's no accuse you know facing your
accuser it's been 10 years of
institutionalizing that type of thought
process and behavior and people who are
senior zen are 32 year old now they're
executives at these corporations and
they're driving the agenda because in
2011 they issued this thing a dear
called dear colleague letter that
changed college campuses and now here we
are seeing the fruits of that 10 years
later
free speech depression and all these
things i'll go on youtube and type bully
fight sometimes or like bully revenge
because i always there's some like
fetish i have where i like seeing a kid
that's getting bullied like turn it
around and fight the bully and win yeah
that's always living like good good for
that kid but now there's a thing pops up
and it says if you need the suicide
hotline call this number if you type if
you search for bully revenge on youtube
there's a
hotline number that pops up that's new
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you